welcome to session five of understanding
anger 2.0 so this is a series that is
kind of a reprise of a talk series that
I did many years ago called
understanding anger and uh this session
is going to be focused on hesiad and how
we see anger and strife depicted and
discussed it primarily in his Works
um the theogony and works and days so uh
this should be an interesting session I
do want to say a little bit about the
understanding anger series particularly
since this is the first one that we are
engaged in live streaming
so understanding anger began as I
mentioned years and years ago I did nine
sessions at the Kingston Public Library
looking at depictions discussions
teachings about anger in a variety of
ancient
literature and primarily philosophy and
then going into the Middle Ages and then
we moved here to Milwaukee so we had to
cut the sessions short unfortunately and
then uh last Academic Year so we're
talking you know fall of 2022 and spring
of 2023 I got to teach a class from
Marquette University several sections of
the class and it was sort of a problems
based class so I decided to focus on
anger something that I do a lot of
research on and then some people were
saying oh I wish I could be in that
class and you know maybe you should do
some sessions on that so I decided to
start doing understanding anger 2.0
and this allows me to go back to and
actually spend a lot more time on the
thinkers texts uh Traditions schools
that I think have something to teach us
about anger and we're we're probably
going to continue this on a monthly
basis you know year after year after
year because there's so many
interesting things that we can look at
so at first we were doing it with zoom
sessions and then I decided you know
let's just do these as YouTube lives and
so you know you'll have the opportunity
and the chat Mark Smith is already
saying uh hello to everybody that's
that's very nice so we can have some
conversations using the chat I'm going
to present about some stuff but we'll
take some time for Q a here and there in
it and I'll catch up with your your
comments doing that as well and we can
have some some great General discussion
I think you do want to make sure that
your comments are on point so this is
not an AMA
this is about hessia this is about anger
this is uh about you know those those
sorts of matters and I'll give priority
to to those but we can get into some
general discussion towards the end of
the session If people really want to do
that so let's start out by talking about
uh why Hessian so this is uh our fifth
session in understanding anger our first
one was very general and then we spent
two sessions looking at anger in Plato's
works and the word that the words that
he's using for anger there are primarily
orge where we're going to talk about why
that's important and then thumos which
is this part of our soul that gets angry
very famous in the uh Republic right and
then we looked at
um we sort of went back in time which is
what we're doing day and we looked at
somebody that Plato references quite
frequently or at least characters in
Plato do and that is Homer and we looked
at the role of anger in its various uh
term senses in The Iliad we'll probably
get to the Odyssey sometime down the
line today we're looking at another
really massively important poet for
ancient Greek and then because of that
ancient Mediterranean culture and that's
Hessian
and hesi it is you know believed to be
roughly a contemporary of Homer we don't
know a ton about the guide and it's not
really that important because this isn't
a biographical thing we're interested in
what we find in his work so what are his
works well one of them is actually
called works and days and it's a long
didactic poem a couple different things
mixed into it some mythology
uh a lot of ethical advice some
complaining about his brother perseis
who apparently has uh taken more than
his fair share of the family wealth and
his you know acting kind of like a jerk
um and then we have the theogony and
theogeny means literally that where they
came from the Genesis of the Divine
beings the theoy and we find that
there's a lot of different ones
discussed in there and uh there's also
an interesting thing called The Shield
of Hercules which we'll talk about
towards the end that uh it's a
description of what's on Hercules shield
and it's also a description of a battle
scene that involves not just this
legendary Hercules but even some of the
Gods uh and the gods that are most
concerned with War Athena and Aries and
then we have all sorts of like bits and
pieces there's you know what we call
um uh testimonials about you know here's
what Hesse had said and these are by
other authors and then we have like bits
and pieces of things that Hessian is
supposed to have written as well
and I I thought it would be good to
begin with one particular line
um which is uh be careful to avoid the
anger of the deathless Gods right and
it's interesting because the translation
there that we see pretty consistently is
not quite literal the term That We're
translating there is anger is actually
opium which means something more like
Vengeance the retribution of the uh
blessed that you know deathless gods and
there's this term
um
which means you're supposed to guard
yourself you're supposed to be on guard
against that and and why well because
the ancient Greek gods at least you know
in the depictions of these
um mythologists these these tellers of
stories they do get angry they
experience this human emotion of anger
just just as much as we do and it's
scarier and more dangerous when the gods
get here because they got so much more
power right and we're going to talk
about some of the interesting
ramifications of this in just a bit so I
thought that would be kind of a good
starting point because you notice that
in the works that we're talking about
there is some discussion of human anger
but it's mostly
referencing the Divine beings of various
sorts and the other thing that I want to
say before we actually get into
analyzing uh parts of the text
is about vocabulary and so if you have
been in on these sessions or you've
watched the the videos for the sessions
before you know that
um the vocabulary the terminology having
to do with anger in ancient Greek is
quite rich and it's going to vary from
author to author and from time to time
in very important ways so one of the
things that I'd like to point out from
the beginning I mentioned this word
right this is a very very common term by
Plato's Time by Aristotle's time you
know by later times and it ends up
becoming probably the most important and
used
term for the emotion of anger but in
earlier authors you don't see it very
often at all so in hessian's works we
find very very few uses of this term
whether as a noun or as a verb that's
that's coming from the noun in works and
days
um we we find out that both Gods and Men
are angry with a man who lives idle and
so what they're saying there is that
there is anger Oregon for this lazy you
know SOB who doesn't do anything that
they're supposed to do but there's also
another term that gets used in there
mesozi
um you know to take to be indignant and
therefore to pursue revenge or
retaliation or punishment of that person
so these things are being connected
together the gods have anger and Men
also have anger at a lazy you know
lollygagger lay about as we would say
particularly one who's you know
succeeding by doing almost nothing
um and the word anger is being used
there later in these fragments the
egomos which are testimonials we're told
that Hessian says that Oaths concerning
the matters of love so Eros do not draw
down Anger orge from the gods and then
in the uh melampodia fragments
um you know some of you may be familiar
with the story of poor charisius who
um winds up being a woman for a while
and you know experiences sexual pleasure
as both a woman and a man and he's used
to settle a dispute between Hera and
Zeus and anytime that that happens
you're really you're screwed one way or
the other so he winds up saying that
women have 10 times as much pleasure in
sex than men hair gets angry she uh the
term there is
right uh or rather or gets that face up
and so she is angered at him and she
punishes him with with blindness and
then Zeus gives him the capacity to
prophesy so that we don't see too much
organ
what do we see
um there's another term that I mentioned
already that we have to be a little bit
careful with thumos so thumos is a word
that often does mean anger but in
earlier writings earlier writers like
um hasid and Homer it also tends to be
sort of like Plato it's part of our soul
it's part of our personality and
sometimes it's used for one's heart or
Soul there's a lot of other language
hater is used for heart friends is is
also used and so we'll see oftentimes
thumos paired with other anger language
saying in the person's thumos in this
part of them that can get angry they
felt anger right so what are the words
that we see being used instead of orge
and instead of sumos
so one of the really big ones is one
that we discussed already when we were
talking about
um a homer and that is holos or holoen
um and this literally means bile that's
coming from your liver but it's used for
getting riled up for getting angry for
being ready to attack somebody else to
fight against them right and so this is
used a lot in in Hessian
cotane and kotos uh means to Bear a
grudge to be angry against somebody and
uh kotos means something like anger or a
grudge that you're holding against
somebody and you hold a grudge because
you want to retaliate which is part of
the uh Central Dynamic of what anger is
Right somebody else did you wrong you
want to do something to them so we've
got two words right there and then we
also have another one that's used a lot
in Homer but but not quite as much in
Hessian it's the one that actually
begins The Iliad Menace right I mean uh
you know I'm not saying Menace as in
like Dennis the Menace but m-e-n-i-s is
how we how we write it typically when
we're transliterating it and uh so he
doesn't use that too often he tends to
use uh these these other terms instead
and then there's another term that I've
already mentioned that comes up quite a
bit uh Nemesis and it's the verb nemes
stain
we tend to think of a nemesis in
contemporary English as like your arch
rival or Arch Enemy right but really a
nemesis is a indignation against
somebody you you think that they did the
wrong thing so you want to punish them
you want to retaliate against them you
you've got this desire it's very close
to anger but it's not exactly the same
thing uh and then we have one other term
that gets used and it's a verb again and
it's used mainly to talk about Zeus in
this case who's going to be a major
player in this this uh set of stories
that we're looking at so we have a
pretty rich anger vocabulary and I'll be
mentioning it as we go along
um signaling which ones are being used
um now do we have any sort of analysis
like we did with Plato or like we're
going to have in the subsequent sessions
with errors bottle of what exactly anger
is how exactly it works no we we're not
getting quite a
in-depth discussion of that and we're
not getting an outlining of like here's
one Dynamic of anger here's another one
instead of just being kind of thrown in
and it's viewed as being
part of the way in which human beings uh
interact with each other and relate with
each other and understand the world and
more importantly the way that the gods
do as well so as a human being you
always got to be a little bit concerned
about not ticking off those Gods because
the gods are not like you know later
ideas where you know God or the Divine
is perfect never screws up these are
pretty
anthropomorphic Gods so I thought we
could start
by talking about
um rivalry and strife and anger among
humans
you know and this is a side note so
hesia doesn't talk as much about anger
as he does about Strife Discord
disagreement uh people being at odds
with each other and the word for Strife
is eres and there is verbal forms for it
as well so one great place to start with
here kind of in the middle of a
discussion very early on is in works and
days there's this really famous passage
that gets brought up by Aristotle and by
other people Potter is angry with Potter
and Craftsmen with Craftsmen and beggar
is jealous of beggar and Minstrel of
minstrel so we've got you know four
paired things where we've got rivalry
going on and notice that there's two
different emotional comportments that
are possible so for the potters and and
for the craft workers the techtone
people who work with their their hands
they can be rival risks with each other
in the sense of getting angry with each
other and the word there is
which is coming from kotos right they
bear a grudge against each other they
they don't like when you you set up shop
right next to each other and then uh
beggar is envious is a better way of
translating it although I mean jealousy
could be that they want to hold on to
what they've got the word there is phone
and that's a a verb from phonos right
which means Envy or something like that
and Bard or Minstrel is
um you know viewing the other one as
their rival now this is all sort of
situated within a longer discussion
where uh Percy or where Perseus is being
educated by his his brother who actually
I mean given the kind of script that
Perseus apparently is according to
hassian maybe
um
he doesn't have any sort of Duty to do
that he's trying to help him out here
and he tells them that there's two
different kinds of strife and strife is
address right
and one of them is praised when
understood the other of which is
blameworthy and here he says something
really really interesting
the translations oftentimes will
kind of mix this up
so the next line is they are divided or
they're different by nature but it's
really they have a divided or twofold
thumos
so the thumos of the person who is
feeling or acting out these kinds of
strife is different any
solar personality so what are these two
different kinds of strife he says one of
these Fosters evil war and battle we get
we get upset with each other we get in
Conflict we're Rivals maybe we get angry
we hold grudges we want to damage and
Destroy and you know push somebody else
out
but he says the other one
stirs up even the shiftless to toil
making a person eager to work when they
consider their neighbor so you look at
other people and you're like oh man
they've got stuff that I wish I had I
guess I'm gonna have to work for it
right and this is a big theme in Perseus
keep your hands off other people's stuff
make make stuff for yourself don't
um you can look to them and say oh maybe
they've got something that I could learn
from them or I I want to Aspire to be
where they are but you're not supposed
to like go over there and steal their
tools or to spoil them of their things
instead you you focus on your own work
and Perseus is told to lay these things
up in his heart and heart there is a
translation of thumos and uh Hessian
tells them don't Let The Strife that
Delights in Badness hold your heart back
from work so the Greek there is eresos
again is is coming up there and the bad
um
the bad heiress the bad Strife is one
that uh Delights in in Badness that sets
its hands to Badness and it's it's it's
you know not supposed to keep you from
ergon doing work doing the things that
you need to do and this is also where
the discussion comes in of gods and
human beings feeling anger towards other
people who are living an idle life who
are you know not doing what they ought
to do to maintain themselves to take
care of things and then he says one
other thing in this so before you know
the right kind of strife is orienting us
to look at our neighbor and say oh I
could you know maybe increase my flocks
like they are or oh they're planting
maybe I should go plant or they just
built a nice building maybe I should you
know fix up my house
he says at a certain point in this
that what we need to do is turn our mind
away from focusing on our neighbors and
instead focus on our own work
so you're not just supposed to be
constantly looking at your neighbors
because if you do you might get you know
upset with them focus on your task and
you'll see an increase in the resources
that you have you know you'll not be so
prone to as he criticizes his brother
for going to the Law Courts and stirring
up trouble right he actually says you
need to have a Year's worth of goods set
aside before you can even think about
going to court and and if you go to
court you know it's kind of a crap shoot
anyway so this is a good place to take
uh some questions we've looked at one
main theme concerning anger here the
Rivalry that we see The Strife between
human beings it can be turned into good
Strife but it's very easy for us to turn
it into bad strife and if we don't want
to work people are going to get ticked
off at us
um
so I I'm gonna skip over seb's question
until like much later because that's
that's very general but does anybody
have any questions about the anger
vocabulary or this first theme of
um you need to to you know pay attention
to the right kind of strife and engage
in the good kind of work otherwise
you're liable to have your Rivals
getting ticked off at you or you get
ticked off at them we want to try to
avoid that anger is very clearly seen
here as on the one hand something that
it would be good for you to try to avoid
feeling and you also want to avoid
becoming the target of other people's
anger by being you know he actually he
talks about drones uh you know in in
beehives that they're they're good for
nothing yeah people will get ticked off
at that so any questions about those
themes
maybe not
um well let's let's move on and if you
do have questions that come up about
that well
jump into them as we go along so another
big key theme I think you could probably
predict
um
oh Daniel has a question should we take
care of jealousy of the gods or the
anger or the thumos or the God so thumos
again not anger right it's where the
gods do have a thumos in the sense of
like having a place where the anger is
felt but that's not usually the word for
it we should take care of both of these
but it's not jealousy of the Gods it's
Envy of the Gods typically we think of
jealousy as like
somebody feels threatened by somebody
else perhaps taking away what they've
got so I I would be jealous if my wife
were talking to somebody else and
appears to be you know very engaged in
flirty conversation I'm envious if I
look at what somebody else has and I say
I want to have that so the Gods the gods
don't really need to be jealous so much
of us human beings but it can be envious
of us you know like if we're too happy
uh and yet has he had and Homer both
think that we need to watch out for that
and so that's one reason for living a
kind of moderate ethical life so this is
a great lead into God punishing human
beings for our transgressions
and Zeus plays a major role in hessian's
works so he says that um Zeus gets angry
and the word there is Aggies and he
punishes
um those who do wrong in various ways
and he gives some examples of this so
being abusive to your father in their
old age when they become vulnerable
they're no longer powerful now you're
the powerful one treating your father
like crap or sleeping with your
brother's wife right going and
committing adultery which violates the
relations uh with your your family
member and casts you know any if there's
somebody that results from it through
pregnancy nobody's sure who the dad is
right and it's also wrong in relation to
the the wife as well or doing wrong to a
supplement so a supply into somebody who
comes to you and says oh help me out
help me out and so if you're like screw
you man I'm gonna throw you in a well
that's doing wrong to them or even worse
to a guest so you notice the examples
that Hessian is using there are uh
determinate relationships he's not like
yeah Zeus will get mad with you for
going up to any old random person on the
street and being mean to them it's more
like the violation of relationships
where there's some sort of expectation
and in works and days later on he'll say
you need to be careful to avoid the
anger not just of Zeus but of the
deathless Gods and then we get a whole
like ethical
Doctrine being laid out there all these
councils about moral life
um some of which have to do with
friendship like who should you be
friends with and
um what should you do when you get in
conflict with your friends and the
friendship seems to be broken he talks
about being wronged and retaliating but
also being ready if the other person is
willing to admit the wrong that they did
to forgive them and restore the
relationship he also has a really
interesting one about not taunting a
person who is poor and he uses like the
you know in the bitterness of their
poverty right so not if you're in a
higher position
not as we say kicking down or punching
down to people who are in worse off
positions he also gives all sorts of
advice about ceremonial matters some of
which is kind of funny but we probably
don't care about that much like you know
you shouldn't urinate in the middle of a
road or something like that you know and
then he has one thing that he says
that's really quite interesting about
these ceremonial manners
he says do not make a mock of mysteries
meaning you know things that are
revealed within the religious life and
then he says because God or the Divine
Theos he doesn't say which God he just
says Theos will take revenge nemesa so
there's that word nemesis again right uh
is the are the gods angry in that case
that maybe not but certainly they're
riled up and they think what you're
doing is the wrong thing and they don't
like it and they're gonna you know
they're gonna do you in for for that so
you know there's this sense of as we see
in other religions uh the Divine taken
interest in our lives they may not be
perfect themselves but they certainly
don't like seeing us being jerks to
other people uh particularly if we're
doing so in relation to those that we
have some sort of commitment to or who
are particularly vulnerable to us
there's a sense that the gods or at
least Zeus looks after the person who's
in a bad condition and then there's this
really interesting story in that gets
told about the races of human beings and
many of you might be familiar with this
and uh anger plays a role in this so
there's five races of human beings and
it starts out with a golden age and a
golden race of people they have a great
easy happy life they don't screw up at
all you know they live a long time and
when they do die they become the good
daimones the good spirits that can be
you know invoked or stuff like that so
they become part of the religious life
of the ancient Greeks
and then we have a silver race that
follows them and these are not so good
they're actually kind of stupid or
foolish is is the way that they're
described and he also says they can't
keep from sinning or doing wrong they
can't keep themselves from falling and
into hamartia error or mistake or you
know doing the wrong thing and
um because of this they couldn't stop
themselves from wronging each other
which we see in the gods don't like that
but they also wouldn't serve the gods
and if there's one thing that's going to
tick the gods off it's not observing the
proper relation to the divine right so
they're unwilling to serve the gods and
Zeus is like all right we're gonna you
know imagine I'm crumpling up a paper
and throwing it away we're going to take
care of this crap these people you know
we're going to
um erase them and started new so so he
says that Zeus gets angry holu menos
right there's that holos again and he
put them away and so they become the
Blessed spirits of the underworld
they're not bad
um but they're kind of scary and they're
kind of you know capricious but you do
have to appropriate them then we get the
people of bronze
they're said to be terrible and strong
they're lovers of Aries the God of War
and of doing violence and Zeus doesn't
even have to take care of them because
they destroy themselves they're
destroyed by their own hands and then in
between our generation and this bronze
generation there's another that's not
identified with any metal whatsoever
these this is a nobler and more just
race and these are hero men he uses the
word hero there uh who we call demigods
half Gods right and some of these are
destroyed by War for example in the
battles around Thebes that you know play
a role in the whole Oedipus Chronicle
um some of them are killed at Troy so
these are these include the heroes of
Troy as well and others Zeus will take
to the end of the Earth and they get to
live in the Isles of the blessed
and by the way Heroes played an
important role in the religion and
ancient Greece as well
you would find shrines to them certain
of the heroes or demigods would actually
become full-fledged Gods like Hercules
um kind of an outlier in that respect
right
others have a bad end some are less
heroic than others and then we get to
our race
the iron race the current race there's
lots of trouble and suffering and
conflict there's a lot of violation of
norms in relations there's many people
who enjoy and desire evil and in two
different places in that discussion
he'll talk in terms of might or strength
being right or goodness now it's not
really that way but this is the way
people portray it and so hesi it is kind
of a pessimist about human Affairs as a
matter of fact if you wanted to liken
this to any other
non-greek text you could think of the
Book of Ecclesiastes right vanity of
vanity all his vanity people do all
these sort of bad things but we're still
supposed to do the right thing even if
we won't necessarily get rewarded for it
because it's the right thing
um maybe the gods will be merciful to us
and all of that
um there's one other thing I want to
bring up and then maybe we'll do some
more q a
twice the story of Prometheus and Zeus
and human beings gets told an anger
figures into that as well
so in works and days we get a shorter
version of the story and we find that
Zeus in the anger of his heart so holos
amenos fresen friends is is your your
like chest and your heart
holosomanos means pissed off angered
right full of holos rage anger uh
um uh desire to to punish
and so in the anger of his heart he hid
from human beings the possibility of
just a little bit of work making plenty
of resources that's why we have to work
like dogs because Zeus who could have
showed us how to live an easy life won't
do it for us and why is he ticked off
because Prometheus tricked him so he
planned sorrow and Mischief against
humans and we see some some misogyny in
here there's some interesting remarks
about women scattered throughout but
Zeus makes women to be a sort of problem
for for human beings and Pandora is is
one of the first of these right you all
know the story of Pandora's Box and
opening it up and all the bad things for
human beings now
why is why is Zeus the most powerful the
gods screwing around with human beings
in this kind of petty and vindictive way
so we find out in the theogony we get
the Fuller story
he's told that Zeus imposes a penalty on
Prometheus Prometheus is one of the
generation prior to Zeus that we call
the Titans right the uh Sons and
Daughters of uh Heaven and Earth so this
is very early on in the story and the
penalty is that he's cast into bonds
that he can't break he's got a shaft
impaling him on this rock through the
middle of his body and then this Giant
Eagle comes by every day to eat his
liver and now notice eating his liver is
kind of funny it's taking away the
possibility of his holos of being angry
right so it's a subjection and
unfortunately because Prometheus is uh
Immortal his liver grows back every day
and so each day it's a fresh new hell
now we find that Hercules now Hercules
is a son of Zeus right Hercules kill
kills that bird and frees Prometheus
Hessian tells us this is not without the
will of Zeus
in this this case so not without Zeus
being okay with it and so he might say
well why did Zeus uh
um get okay with it and you know
hessian's answer is you know so Hercules
could have his glory
um but what we read here is that Zeus is
angry but also ceases from his anger so
he is he was angry right uh but then
palthe
he uh ended he ceased his holos so he is
full of holos and then he's he's not
anymore and where did this anger come
from well Prometheus screwed with him
twice
so the first time is Prometheus divides
up portions of an ox for him and Zeus to
share and he gives Zeus uh some stuff on
the top part that looks really great
then it's all crappy stuff you know like
the bones and things like that and he
keeps uh the better share over here and
then he's like hey Zeus you get to
decide which of these you want and Zeus
figures out what what uh Prometheus is
is up to so he doesn't like that
um he gets angry about the trick right
and we see Jose De frenas so he's he's
angry about the trick and he's angry not
just at Prometheus but for a weird
reason human beings too maybe because
they're the ones sacrificing and then we
read
holostumo so he has holos anger in his
his thumos
and so that's the that's the start
that's the beginning of the beef we
could say right
so he won't give human beings fire and
this goes back to the like you know Zeus
could have made it easy for human beings
but he doesn't do it fire really does
change the game for human beings right
so he won't give human beings fire uh
Prometheus sneaks in I think many of you
are familiar with the story hides a
little Cinder in his read uh pipe and
then we find out that Zeus learning of
this is stung in spirits right and again
we see thumon being the word that's
translated as Spirit there
and his dear heart is angered filon hey
Torres his dear heart and
he has again holos bile in his heart and
he does this because
um Prometheus engaged in Hubris in doing
wrong and insulting him so he feels like
Prometheus has wronged him directly by
helping out these human beings and so
you know he's gonna he's gonna impose a
penalty on Prometheus which only the
intervention of this demigod who then
eventually becomes a god Hercules his
son is able to resolve so good place to
take some more questions and answer if
you've got any remarks about these
points
um and then we're going to go on to the
theogony itself and look at some of the
crazy stuff that's depicted there and
we'll we'll also finish up by looking at
the shield of Hercules but any any
questions about the punishment of human
beings the Prometheus thing uh this
whole thing about the races of human
beings and what a you know crappy age
we're in even though it's an age where
we have fire you know which is pretty
good right
foreign
in the meantime while people are perhaps
writing things I'll I'll say just a few
things
um about half-seed
um obviously he's not cited quite as
often as Homer in the philosophical
literature about anger but he is
important you know
um sometimes there's a bit of digression
just I'll say this in case anybody's
gonna write a question
um people will talk about Homer and
hessia being the Bible for the Greeks
and that's not quite correct I mean
Bible means a whole bunch of books right
and
um it's not as if that was the only
stuff that they look to obviously other
forms of poetry like the tragic and
comedic poets and lyric poets were
important for them as well but you could
say that they certainly enjoyed a high
status and the one way in which they
were kind of like
um
the Bible is that people do what's
called proof texting where they write
um or they they write or they bring up
or they they throw out like little
passages taken out of context and you
know sometimes you're supposed to know
the context well people would do that
with Homer and hussied quite a bit you
know and so all of these ethical
injunctions they might get brought up by
somebody else so Mark says seems like
people have been getting grumpy about
generational differences for a long time
the president always sucks compared to
the good old days yeah although Hessian
is actually saying this was the good old
days were way before any of us were born
right but I think you are quite correct
and and we can steer this into thinking
about anger
um when you go back in time you find
people uh for hundreds and hundreds of
years saying you know this new
generation of kids they're they're they
don't have any respect they're no good
they don't follow Traditional Values you
know and once you see enough of this
stuff you know like recurring as
complaints through the history of ideas
you you kind of get the sense that maybe
some of these complaints are not as
Justified as people make them out to be
and that maybe it has to do with like
getting old and not being happy about
the fact that other people now are you
know the initiative lies with them this
this notion of like youth culture began
in the 50s not really true you know
um as most General relation
generalizations aren't in in when it
comes to the history of ideas and human
beings all right well let's let's talk
about the theogony so the theogony is a
big big story a poem about where did all
these Divine creatures come from or not
even creatures these Divine beings that
came into being
um because they weren't like created as
such they were more generated right so
the the gorny part is is important and
um you know it begins with with uh chaos
and Heaven and Earth and all that and
then uh one of the important points
given our theme of of strife and anger
is that Strife eres is herself a
um goddess right so Heaven and Earth
have their children and Heaven hates his
first children he hides them in secret
places of the earth and he Delights in
his evil doing and then Earth suggests
they take revenge and you know who's
actually going to step up it's Kronos
Kronos who's going to become the king of
the Gods after that well Heaven is about
to have sex with uh his you know Kronos
is his dad is going to have sex with his
mother
um Kronos comes up and castrates his dad
he's got a sickle and cuts his his nuts
off and uh yeah you know there's blood
that drops on on the earth
the peaceful ones come from the spirits
of Revenge he throws uh uh the testicles
into the um the ocean and Aphrodite
comes out of the foam right there's all
sorts of cool stories there and then
there's others as well the fates are
born from nook's night and you know
Hessian has an interesting thing to say
about them they give humans their good
and evil and they pursue transgressions
of human beings but also the gods even
the gods are subject to the fates and he
says they don't cease from their dread
or scary anger
denials once again holos right uh Danos
means scary frightening terrifying and
they don't cease from that until they
punish
Knight also generates Nemesis this the
spirit of uh what we've talked about is
like you know punishing getting revenge
indignation but also a whole bunch of
other things deceit and friendship
hateful age and then hard-hearted Strife
Strife is
hard-hearted cartero thumo
having a enduring thumos having a hard a
can push through it all a ruthless
thermos you could say and then Strife
has a bunch of children in her own turn
she's quite productive it doesn't say
who she uh sleeps with but we do have
some cases where you know there's what
we what it's called parthenogenesis
right
um having children without bringing
forth children without having sex so
Strife begins toil forgetfulness famine
Sorrows fighting battles murders
manslaughters quarrels lying words
disputes lawlessness and ruin and
they're said to be all of One nature or
better yet character uh soon atheists
means in relation to each other so you
could say
um like to each other and then soon
together and atheists so ethos is
character right so
um this is quite interesting and then
she throws or he throws in one other one
oathos who goes after those who take a
false oath
so Strife is very very productive right
and creates all sorts of things that
could be manifestations of anger or
arouse anger or provoke anger
um and then we come back to coronos
after all of this and this beget that
and there's many more stories in there
Kronos is trying to avoid being overcome
by his own child as Earth and Heaven
tell them is going to be the case
because it's sort of Revenge for what he
did to his own father so what does he do
he has sex with Rhea
and he swallows all of his children or
at least he thinks that he does and
um Raya is you know grieved at this she
wanted ever her babies and have them
grow up and so she consults with her
mother and father Earth in heaven about
how Payback
can be imposed for their children and
for kronos's father
and um the the terms there tisaito uh
news
so how can payback be
imposed on her her husband and so you
know Zeus is brought up in secret Chrono
swallows a stone Zeus grows up they get
him to throw up and now there's war
between Kronos and all of his buddies in
his generation and Zeus and this new
generation of of gods and they fight for
10 years
um and it's very bitter fighting said to
be with bitter wrath right uh holos is
again used there Hollows towards each
other and
um
then Zeus decides to bring the other
Titans who are not on the side of Kronos
and his Titans out of these secret
places of the earth these are the really
powerful uh Titans that that uranos
originally stuck down there in places
like like Tartarus you know like the
hundred-handed ones who can pick up 100
rocks and throw them all at the same
time you know and these allies
um being delivered from their murky
gloom and merciless bonds
um
begin fighting on the side of the Gods
against the Titans and Zeus himself like
takes you know he he goes into
let's call it wrath mode
um he has his heart filled with wrath
and once again holos is the word that's
being used there
and he um goes and he like starts
throwing lightning bolts around and they
win
and the the Titans lose uh and then
there's one other interesting fighting
story in there that that comes up as
well
um typhoon is is another create or
another generated uh God we get the word
Typhoon from this and Typhon is one of
the most powerful but Zeus defeats him
throws him again into Tartarus uh in the
bitterness of his anger thumos is used
there in a in one of the few places
where it's it's being used to designate
anger and not just where anger is
and the other thing that comes up in the
theogony that's quite interesting
we find out that Hera is furious with
and quarreled with Zeus so these are you
know the two key themes that we're
talking about here quarreled with is
erisa has Strife with quite literally
and then is furious with uh many say is
is another term that's that's being used
for anger here and it's not used a lot
in Hessian and it means something like
to be furious with to have a lot of
anger in relation to somebody so here at
why is she furious with Zeus because
you'll screw everything that moves you
know and he doesn't listen to her very
much and so this is where it gets really
quite interesting she has have faced us
on her own without having sex with Zeus
she brings him forth
um just out of herself
and so we've got a lot of anger going on
in the theogony all these strifes
between God some of which you could say
are like proto-political who's going to
be in charge who's going to rule some of
which are domestic that have to do with
you know the relationship between
husband and wife as we see with uh Hera
and then we've got this very interesting
kind of you know the universe is filled
with strife and strife produces all
these things that are productive of
anger reflective of anger
um you know prolonging of anger fighting
battles murders lawlessness ruin all of
these sorts of things and this is the
way that that um again hessia is
depicting the universe that human beings
live within as kind of a tough one
there's Gods but
there's all sorts of other beings as
well that you know
um are not you know they're part of the
moral landscape but it's not a beautiful
moral landscape we could say and you got
you really got to watch out for them
even with the gods they can get ticked
off at you and then you know you can get
in trouble so you should be a good
person but goodness isn't necessarily
rewarded and
um Badness isn't always punished in the
way that it it should be so it's it's a
very interesting moral universe that's
being depicted here in terms of strife
and in terms of anger so before we look
at the shield of Hercules and start
wrapping up or opening things up to more
general questions any
questions about the theogony or any of
the other stuff that we've looked at so
far and asead's works uh respecting
anger
foreign
waiting for anybody to ask any questions
I'll I'll mention you know so there's
these two main works and then there's
this thing we call the shield of
Hercules which is a very interesting
composition as I mentioned it's about
like I would say more than half of it is
about just depicting what did The Shield
of Hercules look like and there's so
much stuff being depicted on there that
either it would have to be very very
tiny
or his shield must have just been
incredibly massive and it is you know
it's often looked at by
um
classicists as a very interesting
example of an artistic depiction of an
artistic object that doesn't really
exist except in the narrative World in
which it's created but it's described in
such uh vividness and detail that we can
imagine it and people must have just
been Spellbound hearing about this and
thinking about it you know
um so that that's that's quite an
interesting feature so I don't see any
any questions maybe there'll be some uh
later on let's talk about the shield of
Hercules then so there's there's the two
things there's the depiction of The
Shield at Great length and then there's
this other depiction of a battle between
Hercules and this other guy
um
is translated in different ways the the
in the Greek for it would be kunkus and
he's a son of Aries right so he's a
demigod himself he's he's a Spearman so
his uh Hercules they fight with Spears
and shield
and let's talk about the shield first
so there's this long long depiction of
The Shield I'm not going to go through
everything but I will say this there's
there's uh three really interesting
features of it
so one is that the shield itself
contains images of pursuit and flight
tumult Panic Slaughter Strife uproar and
fate fate understood as a single
individual not as the three individuals
so you know we don't get like great
descriptions sub-descriptions of these
we're just told that these are on the
shield and you can see them on that
shield and then we get all sorts of
other descriptions and many of them
include animals but many of them also
include men who are fighting like around
a city and stuff like that and I think
the most interesting one has to do with
um lions and
boars glaring at each other
on it now the boar and the lion are both
aggressive animals right and as a matter
of fact we see in Hercules's own story
he has to overcome a lion he has to
overcome a boar these are pretty scary
creatures particularly in ancient times
and there were in fact Lions still in
Europe at the time
um there are still wild boars in Europe
I remember when I was in the Army in
Germany we could hear them snuffling
around in the forest when we were
marching at night and I was thinking to
myself holy crap if one of these goes
after us we've got these unloaded you
know M16s they're not going to do
anything against these you can like poke
them with it but they're not going to
care these are these are scary Fierce
creatures right and so
um
the Lions and the boars are depicted as
like ready to fight with each other and
as being on two sides and they are
furious with each other uh cotton they
are filled with kotos with with rage
against each other and they are being
roused to fight by their very anger kote
um so we've got a depiction of anger
both embodied in these kinds of
creatures and in their relation to each
other on this Shield which is a you know
part of the arms of War
Ares himself
is also on the shield
so interestingly Aries who's playing a
role in the story
is on Hercules's shield and we're
getting it this narrated by Hessian
so what happens
um Athena shows up and gives uh Hercules
some advice he says listen after you
kill uh uh
um Aries his father is going to show up
and try to fight you here's where you
can wound Aries himself the God of War
here's where you can wound it an
immortal
so uh Hercules and uh kooknas fight each
other and it's said that they fight each
other like lions springing on each other
in Fury and the same word is used once
again
Tes right so they are like the Lions on
the shield but now they are lions
springing in Fury against each other and
there's a you know interesting battle
scene that takes place obviously who
wins Hercules and then Aries comes on
and how does he come on like a lion
whose dark heart
melifrono is filled with rage and here
again we see
for you know one of the few times thumos
being used to do is a synonym for anger
no longer as the part because the for
the the you know uh friends is where
um the uh anger is is is being felt
so uh Athena herself you know they fight
back and forth and all that
and Athena herself intervenes and tells
Aries to hold back his anger here we see
another anger word being used a fairly
rare one uh Menace the one that's used
of Achilles's rage right she tells Ares
to hold back his his anger because it's
not ordained that he should kill
Hercules but Ares doesn't care he's he's
angry he's he's you know going after him
so he goes after Hercules and then
Hercules wounds him Hercules is able to
wound a God and not just any God but the
God of War itself and then Ares exits
the scene and you know Hercules is
triumphant through the the help of
Athena who's by the way the big arch
rival of Aries you know they will
actually clash in The Iliad towards the
end of the uh the work
um when the gods themselves are fighting
each other so we have again very suggest
positive interesting idea about these
warriors uh
human and God well our demigod and God
fighting each other
a lot of likening to Lions who are
emblematic animal when it comes to rage
at least for the ancient Greeks I'd say
for many other cultures as well so
that's that's all that I've got for you
um we've got you know some time if
people have questions
comments want to engage in in further
discussion I will take uh Subs more
general question now while other people
are writing
um things down can you give some tips
about formative philosophical works
primarily in the ancient tradition that
expound on a wealth of practical
philosophical Concepts stuff to really
dig into so
yeah every one of the main schools of
philosophy that we have from ancient uh
Mediterranean culture
he has a lot of practical philosophical
Concepts it really depends on how you're
reading it so let's take Plato as a good
starting point right there's way more
going on in platonic dialogues than
summaries of platonic dialogues or
approaches that say what is the main
argument here or what is the topic here
and does Socrates adequately resolve it
then those can bring to to light I'll
give you a prime example in the Mino
it's viewed as an operatic dialogue
because they don't they don't make it to
a finish point you know there's an opera
being stuck in place they never do
manage to Define what virtue is
but they do teach you a lot of things
about virtues along the way including
the Primacy of two of the virtues in
particular Justice and practical wisdom
right so if you're paying close
attention to the text and you're not
just like looking at what's the main
point
you find all this incredible stuff along
the way
um you know Plato doesn't have any place
where he says okay now we're going to
talk about anger at Great length but you
can take the things that he has to say
and piece them together and get a very
interesting coherent idea of what anger
is and how it matters and how we can
deal with it same thing for Aristotle
and the whole Aristotelian tradition
right and I should mention that Plato if
we talk about platonism Plato's just the
starting point we have all sorts of
important neopla or yeah neoplatonists
at the the hind end and then middle
plateness like Plutarch who has a wealth
of of writings and elkinus and a few
others
um Aristotle the Aristotelian tradition
continues on all the way to people like
Alexander of aphrodisias we have the
whole stoic tradition
um which you know we isn't just confined
to authors like Epictetus and Marcus
Aurelius and Seneca and mussonius Rufus
and Heracles we have summaries of stoic
Doctrine and diogenes Laertes and Arias
didimus neither of whom are stoics and
in Cicero who's not a stoic himself but
who thinks that that's important so now
we've got three main philosophical
traditions we've also got the Epicurean
tradition we've lost a lot of epicurus's
writings but we know a lot about what
the epicureans thought and taught and we
do have some later writers and there's a
skeptic tradition there's the cynic
tradition you know there's all these
really rich things and then we could say
well what what Beyond philosophy
we have literature and that's part of
what we're studying in like this session
you know
and in later sessions where we're going
to look at tragic poetry like that of
echelus and uh Sophocles and euripides
and there's teaching about things going
on in those but not in a directly
philosophical manner but in a quasi
philosophical Manner and then you know
as we move into late Antiquity and we
see the importance of certain religious
perspectives particularly Judaism and
Christianity but also a kind of uh
neo-paganism uh arising we have all
these great authors who are taking in
the insights from these earlier schools
and placing them in a new framework and
thinking through those things so lots
and lots of of people movement acts that
you know are these formative
philosophical works that expound on a
wealth of practical philosophical
Concepts I mean the the thing that's I
won't say sucks about that because it
all depends on how you look at it is
there's almost too much for you to
really
read and assimilate and make your own
um
within the you know the scope of a
Lifetime right once you start digging
into it
all right
um
Daniel Is the destiny of the three
sisters somehow a kind of uber got a
principle of universal justice
anticipation of the form of justice and
the good I would say no no
um primarily uh and it's not the destiny
it's the fates plural right
um and Destiny and faith not not exactly
the same thing you wanna you wanna stick
with with that
um
uh the fates are the the ones who punish
gods and and men but it doesn't say that
they punish fairly right and you don't
need them necessarily in the picture to
already have Justice and goodness and
you know it I I would also not worry so
much about
um the form of Justice
and the form of the good as we find them
in Plato because uh hessia doesn't have
anything remotely like that and the form
of justice is not so Justice is one of
the the four cardinal virtues maybe five
if we take the protagoras into account
right and the form of the good is also
the form of the beautiful that we find
in the symposium
but and we're just talking about this
actually uh at a recent conference the
form of justice is not the same thing as
the form of the good in Plato as far as
we can tell right uh it's one of the
other forms that are
contributed to by the form of the good
or the the beautiful but I wouldn't read
the I wouldn't read the fates into that
they're they're darker they're they're
not as I mean with Plato If you
experience the form of beauty or the
form of the good you're like oh this is
so wonderful there's nothing bad about
the experience right whereas running
into the Fates
not usually so good right
uh Power does God exist irrelevant to
this this discussion Mark anger is such
a rich theme for storytelling
fascinating to see it portrayed in such
a diverse set of conflicts from
political and domestic to Cosmic yeah
good cosmological in hessian's works
that that's very true
um that's that's a term I should have
used before
um cosmological so I mentioned that we
have like domestic and we have like
quasi-political you could call it social
right but this is indeed cosmological
hessia doesn't say that the universe is
fair but he does think that there are
you know sort of like Norms that are
woven into it in some you know weird
probably contradictory way that we can
access and uh live up to at least to
some degree and we'd better do that
because there's other beings out there
more powerful than us that also care
about these things and so if we don't
care enough about them they will see
what we do and punish us
right so kind of a kind of an
interesting uh
uh thing you know and you get the idea
that the world that Hessian lives in
it's not a very pleasant world is it
um but you know I think he thinks of
himself now we wouldn't say he's being
realistic right because we don't believe
in like all the Greek gods or stuff like
that but
um for his time perhaps we could say
that he is being
very realistic right
any other questions comments
um
concerns things that people want to
bring up
[Music]
still getting
woken up by my coffee while people are
writing I'll just mention a little bit
of trivia I was out pretty late last
night with my oldest kid
um
here at the world's largest Music
Festival Summerfest that's been going on
for more than 50 years in the Milwaukee
area right right downtown right on the
lake
and we got to see a bunch of metal bands
and actually I mean this could actually
tie in so
um we saw Vixen who were amazing uh we
saw Queen's right that was the Ender of
the night and then in between we saw
Stephen Adler
who has Guns and Roses original drummer
and he did a lot of the songwriting and
it was basically Guns and Roses tribute
band with one original member and then
we saw autograph before that an
autograph people know from Turn up the
radio
um and you know they didn't really have
any other big hits but they're kind of a
fun party Band Vixen was was really
quite something and what was really cool
with Queensryche who are a you know
early Prague metal band
you know everything got turned up
because they're the headliners and so
the base was really strong and the
bassist is like the original guy and
he's really really good and bass is
incredibly important for uh heavy metal
um you know you've got the guitars kind
of screaming and and doing things like
like uh you know big riffs and all that
and you know great drumming and the the
singer is one of the most he's a
replacement for Jeff Tate who is one of
the most operatic singers in heavy metal
so hearing some of these songs that I've
been hearing for decades and decades you
know like in my headphones or on car
speakers or stuff like that hearing them
actually played live it is quite a
spectacle
and you know there's a lot of like
discussion how angry is heavy metal
music there's certainly a connection
between
aggressivity and that but interestingly
research is borne out that four fans of
heavy metal
um listening to heavy metal which will
sometimes rile other people up is
actually a calming thing you sort of
slip into the music now that's that's a
bit of a digression uh Mark has some
questions here any interesting
comparisons you would draw between
Hessians and Homer's depictions of the
Gods anger are there fairly consistent
in their portrayals or are there notable
differences
so
um and demigods anger
I would say that they're consistent in
that the Gods are not particularly good
at controlling their anger right they
they get angry at each other at human
beings
pretty easily there is
um sometimes you know
like talking with each other and saying
you need to control your anger but it's
much more frequent that like they just
get angry with each other and then do
things so I would say you know that that
actually
um fits in quite well
healthy use of aggression and anger
individuate the shadow I'm not a fan of
of jungian Concepts so I don't I don't
you know think of things in terms of the
shadow
um but you know there is there is
something it was very interesting Plato
Aristotle both talk about the capacity
for different modes of music to
arouse our emotions in different ways
and you know catharsis is one of those
terms that
um gets used so much that it's almost
become kind of a cliche
um originally it means like purification
or cleansing
and interestingly where it comes up you
know like for example in Aristotle's
Poetics it's not about catharsis of
anger but rather of pity and fear
um but there's no reason why anger
couldn't be included in it
um
and there's nothing to say that it
couldn't have different effects on
different people depending on their
psychologies right so this is why you
could have people you know parents in
particular being worried about why are
you listening to that angry music it
sounds so angry and you'd be like well
it's not making me angry it might be
making you angry right uh Daniel says
Homer is heavy metal for me when
Achilles is fighting uh hanatos
um
yeah I mean it's not as if metal is
unique in depicting or invoking
aggressivity and anger
um and not all metals like that I mean
if any of you have seen the show
metapocalypse and you think about
um the different characters involved so
this is an adult swim show that had like
the ideal black metal band called Death
Clock and you know they've got the super
talented guitarist Swiss car they've got
you know a drummer who's from Wisconsin
pickles they've got Nathan explosion
who's sort of like a bigger Dumber Glenn
Danzig
um uh who's the singer and the band
leader and then they've got William
murder face murder face as the bassist
and then there's this guy Toki and Toki
is also Scandinavian I believe that he's
Norwegian and swiss car is Swedish and
swisscar won't let him play any solos or
stuff like that he's stuck in in rhythm
guitar because he's he's definitely not
as good as as uh uh swissgard who's
constantly playing and you know when
they play and they do have like music in
the cartoons
um it's like legitimate death metal you
can actually buy their albums and it's
very aggressive very harsh right so all
these morbid themes when they're allowed
when Toki is allowed to be on his own
he makes songs about rainbows and fuzzy
bunnies and stuff like this he doesn't
quite fit the the ethos and I would say
that there's there's you know there's
some heavy metal that's more like toki's
style you know and then there's the
hedonistic stuff too right you've got
um uh
uh pickles used to be in the band snakes
and ladders which is obviously supposed
to be guns and roses and
you know that's all about like uh
debauchery and doing cocaine there's
even a uh guy there's a character who's
modeled after David Lee Roth called roxo
The Rock and Roll clown
who is his key line is you know I do
cocaine right
um and so you know metal can have all
different uh aspects there could be the
very aggressive dark aggression for its
own sake angry right there can be the
hey we just like to party man you know
think about uh kiss as a band right rock
and roll all night and party every day
that's not so much about aggression is
it
um so there's a wide spectrum and we can
say similar things about other musical
genres as well now we're getting kind of
far afield from Hessian but it's an
interesting digression nonetheless
any other questions comments
um while you're writing stuff down I'll
mention that in the sessions to come
we're going to be spending the next two
months on Aristotle we're going to begin
with looking at what he has to say about
anger in rhetoric book two that's really
the first
let's call it you know
systematic psychological examination of
anger in Antiquity so Aristotle is kind
of a groundbreaker and then we're going
to look at what he has to say in other
works like the nick of McCain and
udamian ethics the politics where it's
about you know a cause of breakdown in
society
um the topics where he's got a number of
like offhand remarks about anger Poetics
as well where we're talking about you
know social uh representation and
products and you know like
plays and in our time TV shows and
things like that
and then we're gonna
look at as we move into the fall we're
going to look at
um some more poetry we're going to look
at Ashley's and the orastea trilogy and
we're going to look at
um
uh
uh euripides Medea and Sophocles Ajax
anger plays a major role in both of
those as well and then we're gonna look
at if I remember right what the
epicureans have to say and we'll get
into a little bit of stoic work by
December so we have a whole lineup and
then we'll start it again the year after
that so we're going to be doing these
monthly sessions like this for quite a
while so I don't see any other um
questions or comments
um
oh corrupt you Ukraine what a weird
title there uh I want to love poetry how
do I do it I don't know I mean read it
read some more you know I don't I don't
know you I don't know your background
your makeup your mental affections or
anything like that and poetry covers a
wide range
um but the one thing you can say is
you're not going to you know with as
with anything else you're not going to
really get to know it unless you spend a
good bit of time with it so maybe that's
where to start
um
any other questions comments
well maybe we'll wrap up here then
thanks for everybody for joining in and
like I said next time Aristotle's uh
rhetoric book two a lot of really great
stuff on anger in there cool stuff in
Hessian if you haven't read hasid it's a
it's a quick read Because The Works and
days theogeny not very long you could
read through all of these things in just
an afternoon
um so that could be you know quite nice
certainly over the weekend you could
read all of Hessian so all right I will
sign off and say I'll see you later on
down the line